we have we have this big story that i
want to get into and uh it's we find
ourselves once again talking about joe
rogan and spotify but this is a good
example of the of the cultural imbalance
so the quick story is that spotify is
announcing an addition of content
warnings
over the criticism of joe rogan and
covet 19 misinformation but we never get
this the other direction when rachel
maddow or fauci or cnn puts out bunk
garbage twitter does not flag them you
put out something that goes against
fauci or mata or cnn twitter flags you
so joe rogan has on sanjay gupta mike
osterholm experts establishment voices
nobody cares right he has on mikola and
um and malone and it's the apocalypse
joni mitchell these old aging hippies
are like i want censorship and then you
know niels lofgren now to be fair they
both both neil young and and lofgren
said we don't want to censor joe rogan
we just want off the platform because we
don't want to share with him okay that's
actually respectable because you know if
i that's the right thing to do if i was
on a platform and i was like i don't
like that they support hate speech right
i'll leave yeah so good bye bye leave
that's good yeah but we can see what
happens from the backlash you're never
going to get a concession from the
establishment to recognize independent
voice it's always the other way around
so long as this imbalance exists we are
all being pulled hard towards the
authoritarian side of things and that
being said
a story like this i think just shows
they have no effective means of stopping
joe rogan real conversations
conversations like this so despite this
being kind of bad here's the big update
spotify shares recover after joe rogan
addressed the vaccine controversy as
taylor swift fans calling her to pull
her music from the streaming service
it's not gonna happen spotify may suck
on pay rates and all that but the moment
they come out and say oh okay we'll do
this little content warning which
ultimately i think will do nothing right
it may be a net negative in certain
capacity the spotify shares rebound and
i think you know joe and everyone else
is going to pull out of this and they're
going to walk away from this unscathed
yeah i think the thing that that that
helps joe rogan here is he's such an
important part of the company because
he's got such a massive audience the
interesting question and i don't know
the answer to it is spotify has a number
of large chinese investors that own
portions of that does that play into
this censorship i don't know we know
with twitter you know jack dorsey hired
senior executives because he wanted to
break into china that had ties with the
communist party
this censorship issue we talked earlier
about it i think we are becoming more
like china china's not becoming more
like us we'll be coming we're importing
some of these censorship tools that they
use well uh what do you think about
blackrock
uh blackrock uh is terrible uh they're
the focus in my book think about this
for a second real quick sorry just uh
yeah can you explain what blackrock is
yeah blackrock is the largest financial
asset manager in the world and and what
does that mean
they manage
10 trillion dollars that's with a t
the gross national product of the united
states is like 21 trillion so they
manage almost like 50
of the united states gross national
product financially so they are the 900
pound gorilla of world finance i want to
show something real quick before we get
into that in reference this is something
i've shown on the show before but we'll
show again in this context this is
something i posted and i want to just
issue the the disclaimer before going
through this
blackrock owns basically everything
right so i'm not trying to post these
things to make an assertion of some
grand conspiracy but i think it's
important to show the business
connections yeah so this is neil young
sells catalog rights to mercur
mercuria
mercuritis's hypnosis
blackstone and hypnosis song management
launch a billion dollar partnership
blackstone announced his appointment of
jeffrey b kindler former chairman and
ceo of pfizer as a senior advisor
spotify to pull neil young's music
objecting to joe rogan so uh not that i
think
it's necessarily evidence that someone
at blackstone you know put to the phone
and said we need to pull a neil young on
this one and get him but it shows that
it very well may have been a meeting
where they're just like look this joe
rogan's show is bad for us it hurts our
profits and shares what are our assets
like well we do have this music catalog
that does work with spotify all right
get them on the phone and see if there's
anything there it's possible it's
entirely possible blackstone it's got
its pinky and everything and it's got
it's got mean it's got uh interests and
a conflict of interest and all of this
stuff yeah i mean blackrock is massive
and huge and uh they
are very interested and supportive of
this kind of authoritarian model so
think about this for a second in 2017
the communist party of china goes to
hong kong you know they have the hong
kong stock exchange all these companies
on it goes to the hong kong stock
exchanges every company listed here
has to
put in its company charter that the
communist party of china gets the final
decision in every corporate decision
now this had to be voted on by the
shareholders in these companies right in
hong kong so vanguard you know big
financial company votes against it
absolutely we do not want this wow
blackrock
voted in favor
but isn't vanguard bad as well yeah i'm
sure they're bad but i'm saying on this
in contrast i mean at least some of them
got right blackrock actually said no we
actually think this is a good idea
what's the what's the gdp of china uh
the gdp of china is is uh you know
probably about 60 percent of the united
states so so
blackrock might be like we can take them
we're getting there yeah for real yeah i
mean but china's growing fast yeah it
has grown fast seven eight percent clip
and they're expected to surpass us in a
few years so i wonder if you know we
look at stuff like joe rogan's show and
the fact that he's just some regular guy
kind of comedian populist being so so
successful
we i look at a lot of this and i'm like
clearly the free speech is winning but
in the long run china's growth outweighs
ours will it matter if we have cultural
victories when the economic victory is
in china's
uh it's a good question and i think it
depends on on what we think the uh the
average american's gonna do i still
think the average american is the center
of gravity ultimately if if the average
american rises up and says we're not
gonna tolerate this they can still win
over elites um and i want to believe
that there's still the fight there right
that
the average american when they see these
things being eroded they get pushed far
enough they're going to stand up and say
push no more we're done yeah but i think
what we saw with the uh with the coveted
lockdowns a good portion of this country
are just like yeah tell me what to do
and i'll do it yeah although they didn't
you know they didn't lock down in
certain states because i knew they
couldn't get away with it but you're
right california new york a lot of
places a lot of people kind of caved
right yeah but like we knew we couldn't
count on them anyway something would
have happened with china oh no the
californians and the new yorkers were no
help well that's that's the scary
future projection it's really funny
there was a
i got a facebook reminder and it was
like old memories and it was a post i
made in 2017 where i was like
authoritarian dictatorship is coming to
the united states it was early 2017 i
said
the conspiracy theory is trump being the
trojan horse for authoritarianism
because he will be demonized and
vilified to the point where it rallies
the left into accepting authoritarianism
and then in the name of stopping the
rise of fascism you get
hardcore far left pro-china
and then you know that it was kind of
just like something i'd say on the
internet and i typed up
but uh there's there's other theories
other other you know i shouldn't say
theories but like
people genuinely believe if it came to
like donald trump winning in 2024 that
people in california would clap and
cheer when china landed you know u-boats
or something on the shores to come in
and save them from fascism or something
like that yeah i mean you look at
history when when dictators have taken
over they never come and say hey i'm
going to be your dictator i'm going to
control your life it's always i'm going
to protect you from this terrible evil
thing that's even worse than me well so
i don't know if you saw the boston globe
story from uh 2020 election where they
said you know it was like podesta and
donna brazile were war gaming as the
democrats and they had pressured the
west west coast states to secede from
the union should donald trump win
now if that kind of sentiment actually
did exist what do you think let's
imagine there is some kind of national
divorce or whatever right and then come
2024 donald trump is like you know got
his hand on the bible and he's like i am
the new 47th president or whatever and
then california oregon washington
they're like yo we out yeah what what
happens i mean does china just see an
opportunity do they just say oh it's
fair game because who's got hawaii now
that the western states are cut off from
the rest of the country
who's going to defend taiwan i mean
actually i kind of think taiwan would
fall before then if that were the case
yeah yeah no i think i think
china of course would love a divided
america and they're pushing for it in so
many different ways and unfortunately
there are
a substantial number of americans i
would say mostly on the political left
although there's probably some on the
right that that actually fear
their fellow americans more than they
fear a regime in china or these other
cases and that that that's just tragic
that's just tragic and
yeah i mean i mean look at the defense
that uh the establishment waged for
china when trump was engaging in the
trade war exactly it was like oh this is
wrong and bad you shouldn't do this it's
going to destabilize the global economy
it's bad for everybody and it's like yo
they have concentration camps like we're
talking about yeah yeah and the chinese
leaders said uh you know that their best
lobbyists were wall street they didn't
have to lobby they didn't have to lobby
i mean they outright said it we don't
have to lobby the trump administration
on tariffs because wall street will do
us for us wow yep unbelievable so where
does that line do you think are are you
familiar with thucydides strap
yes do you think we for those aren't
familiar it's a you know a rising
economic power
reaching the dominant power it typically
results in war do you think we're headed
in that direction uh i i think so in a
way but i also think there's a very real
opportunity i think china is a
brittle regime i don't think it has the
widespread support that people think it
does i think it's very akin to the
soviet union you have this cast of
people on the top that benefit from the
system but you've got a lot of people
that are resentful of it in china you
have the economic growth you didn't have
in the soviet union but you have a huge
problem in the fact that you know china
had this one child policy for so long
and so what ended up happening was um
you know parents wanted to have one
child they wanted to be a boy they
didn't want to be a girl because a boy
is going to provide for them in their
old age so the estimates are that in
some cases you know within a demographic
group of like 25 to a 40 year olds there
may be like 150 million more men in
china than there are women now that that
is grounds for
a civil war in that country yes no no
joke i mean look you wanna you wanna get
serious for a minute and also people are
gonna laugh and probably roll their eyes
especially the feminists but
150 million more men you said yes so
those are going to be guys who can't get
women can get dates in cells seriously
and they're going to they're going to
lose it right i mean it's not it's not
about making fun of neckbeard it's not
about making fun it's about young men
who have literally no opportunity to
to fulfill a a a massive internal desire
for having a family right and they are
going to have nothing yeah they're going
to lose their minds well when you look
at the vast majority of the crime
problem in this country including really
heinous
insane crimes that rarely occur such as
massacres or school shootings or whether
it's just street crime like a burglary
they're almost all committed by men who
feel as if they have no buy-in to the
system and they have no way to rise up
and be successful and a huge part of
that
is the ability to start a family right
and if you don't believe that there's
any hope for that you're going to become
a deranged individual if you don't have
that hope it's so necessary and it's
such an important part of being a man
and a productive person in general and
so if china has 150 million men who have
no prospect of ever being with a woman
that is going to be
unbelievably and horrifically damaging
to that country except colonization yeah
so we are seeing the modern form of
colonization from china as many people
who live there to escape crowding and
find better you know
better better lives are leaving the
country so a lot of these young men
might just say i've got to leave china
and go somewhere else to try and find a
life and i just want to make this clear
what i'm talking when i'm talking about
men who have no buying to the system i'm
not i'm not talking about like oh
they're not accountable for their
actions or something like that but the
link i'm trying to draw is usually when
we talk about someone like a school
shooter for example we'll we'll
highlight the fact that this was an
in-cell
right and like these are it's really
it's not exactly the perfect term for it
but it's like you have 150 million in
cells you could get them vr porn and but
i don't know if
people in a machine with digital
pornography is enough to make them not
psychotically i mean it's another kind
of psychosis and i got to say that's
absurd obviously you get them waifu body
pillows yeah yeah well i'm talking about
after i was i thought that that one
already hadn't worked out
yet so we had to i wonder if china's
going to stick a bunch of people in pods
try and generate their piezoelectric
heat for electricity and a little hope
they don't go crazy i'm with you to a
certain degree in like uh vr girlfriends
and stuff like that to try and uh you
know or like robots or something to try
and you know
calm the rage
but uh i i don't know about harness you
know pulling a matrix on them in that
capacity maybe maybe a little too
premature i think i think um leaving the
country is a more i think
i think we're going to see
waves of you know
adult chinese men just moving out and
trying to find wives in other places so
now if we can think 20 years in the
future what would we do now to present
an environment for those people to come
because we need to
make way for these displaced chinese men
yeah i don't know yeah i mean it's it's
it's a good question i mean it it to me
it's one example of the fact that china
has problems too it's not like they're
this super power that can't be
uh you know uh defeated that that
they're inevitably going to be more
powerful than us uh so i think we need
to recognize that and we need to play to
our strengths not played to their
strengths and i think you know when you
look at china the problem is the chinese
communist party it's not the chinese
people um you know reagan said that in
the cold war our enemies are not the
russians it's this it's the soviet
leadership and i view the same way with
china we've gotta have that reagan sorry
trump did some of that in his speaking
um his secretary of state did the same
thing joe biden lumps it all together
china is china it's not you've got a
clique that's running the country uh
that is oppressing the rest of them and
then you've got the ordinary chinese who
you know cannot be that happy with the
chinese communist party thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you